đồng bào, đồng chỉ, chế chi càng nước và đồng bào tàn nước ngoài.
Sơn bính ngọt đã tới trong thời các chuyển rau, năm củ, năm mới,
tôi sẽ nói người tối đồng bào, đồng chỉ, chế chi càng nước và đồng bào tàn nước ngoài,
lời chúc năm mới, anh lành, mạnh phẻ vài khúc.
Tôi chân trong người tối như rất bàn bè khúc tế, những lời chúc tốt đẹp nhất.
Chúc 1 năm mới hoài bên, hành phúc và cùng phát triển.
Năm tị, hành in thế làm, đất nước thà đã đi qua một chẳng đường,
vì giống nhiều sự kiện quan trọng, poin nghĩa đặc biệt và đảyng nhiều thành tiêu,
sức đá từ hà, đồng thời, cũng là một năm đến nước thà về trải qua,
rất nhiều khó khăn thử thách với như quyết động ngành, phức thạp,
khó lường của thế giới và khó vực.
Công những thiết thái khắc nghiệp, kế tổn thách nặng này để lại nhiều đau thương mất mắt cho đồng bào tàn.
Băng bản lý kinh kương, gií chi tư lực từ kương, toàn đảm, toàn rất toàn cuối tá,
đoàn kết, chúng sức đồng lòng, phát vì sức mạnh, toàn rất tỏ, và sự giúp đốc của bạn bè khúc tế.
Chúng ta đã hoàn thành toàn bố khámu kêu trụ giữa để ra với nhiều giới nội bật.
Đặc lập trụ quyền thống nhất, toàn vẻ đến thỏ, mối trường hà bên, được giúp vấn.
Tăng trở bị tế, tổn gõm rất đau, để giới.
Chòa thành nước có thu nhập trung mình cao.
Anh chỉ giáo ở được quan tâm, chăm lo, chính chỉ giáo ở ở đây,
của phòng anh đến được giúp vấn và trăng cường.
Đối ngoài, ở nhập khúc tế được đầy mạnh,
vì thế, vi tiến, COVID-19, kết tục nất cao trên trường khúc tế,
tào nít tả quan trọng để đến nước bước vào kỳ quyết phát triển mối,
bước sang năm mới, bính ngọt, hàng y thay sảo,
năm đầu tiên thực hiện nghị quyết đại hội mối bống của đảng.
Bối trình thống yếu nước nồng nàn, tinh tình, gòn kết,
ý chi kinh cường và khách vọng với linh mạnh mẽ,
toàn đảnh, toàn dân, toàn cuất ta sẽ tiếp tục gòn kết,
chung sức đồng lòng, tần dụng mối thật kêu vấn hội,
vừa thóa mối khó khăn thách thức,
bắt vì mạnh mẽ tinh tàn tự tiên, tự chủ,
tự lực, tự cường, tự hảo trên tộc.
Không ngừng đổi mới sáng tạo,
hành động quyết liệt, để hiến tự quát, thành công,
một thiếu xe dựng đất nước Việt Nam hoa bên,
được lập rất trù, rau mạnh, phần viên, vấn viên, hành phúc.
Chóng liền vui đó chào, vừa xin mỗi.
Một lần nữa, tự chủ đồng bào,
đồng chi, chiếc xí cả nước và đồng bào ta nước ngoài.
Năm mới, thẳng lợi mới, thành công mới,
dân tộc và như dân thà này cảnh thị vương,
khó khổ sống ấm nó, tự gió hành phúc.
Chào, tân nãy và quyết thêm.